unter Verwendung von GPT 6.1. Ich habe
also einen vollständigen Klon von
Elden Ring erstellt. Und das ist ein
Detailgrad, den ich von diesem Modell
wirklich nicht erwartet hätte. Ein
Modell, das super kosteneffizient ist,
kann eine solche Qualität liefern. Und
es ist einfach wahnsinnig. Es gibt so
viele coole kleine Funktionen, die
hinzugefügt wurden, um das
Originalspiel fast zu replizieren, was
bei den Soundeffekten, der Musik und
all den anderen Elementen wirklich
verrückt ist. Es ist also insgesamt
wirklich beeindruckend, dass wir dieses
kleine, günstige Modell haben, das in
der Lage ist, so etwas zu generieren.
Wir hatten heute einen ereignisreichen
Tag, da OpenAI den Dev Day veranstaltet
hat und überraschenderweise mit der
Einführung von GBT 6.1 Soul auf Sonet
5.5 reagierte, nur eine Woche nach der
Veröffentlichung von GBT6 Soul. Das
ist absolut verrückt und es ist
unglaublich, wie sie es geschafft haben
, in so kurzer Zeit ein weiteres
wichtiges Modell nachzutrainieren und
zu veröffentlichen. GBT 6.1 Soul liegt
im Wesentlichen auf dem Niveau von
Astra Intelligence, kostet aber nur ein
Fünftel des Preises, was es zu einem
der kosteneffizientesten Modelle für
seine Leistungsstufe macht, das heute
verfügbar ist. Die ganze Idee dahinter
ist es, Frontier-Intelligenz
erschwinglich genug zu machen, damit
Sie sie für mehr Ihrer täglichen
Arbeit nutzen können, während
Entwickler Anwendungen in großem
Maßstab erstellen und ausführen
können, ohne ihr Budget komplett zu
sprengen. Und nach dem, was ich bisher
gesehen habe, sieht GBT 6.1 Soul
wirklich nach der Art von Modell aus,
die man als täglichen Begleiter nutzen
möchte. Aber ehrlich gesagt gibt es
noch so viel mehr, worüber wir bei
diesem Modell sprechen müssen. Bleiben
Sie also unbedingt dran, denn später
im Video werden wir GPT 6.1 Soul
vollständig testen und sehen, wie gut
es wirklich ist. Aber das war bei
weitem nicht alles, was OpenAI am Dev
Day angekündigt hat. Sie haben endlich
Dots enthüllt, den ständig aktiven
Agenten, über den wir in unseren
Leak-Videos berichtet haben. Er bekommt
seinen eigenen Computer, funktioniert
in über 4.000 Apps und kann rund um
die Uhr proaktiv im Hintergrund für
Sie arbeiten. OpenAI hat auch den 200-
Dollar-Pro-Plan zurückgebracht, wenn
auch mit halber Nutzungskapazität, und
„Ultra Fast“ eingeführt, das bis
zu 300 Token pro Sekunde in Codex
bietet und bei API-Generierungen bis zu
sechsmal schneller ist. Die Codeex
Security Cloud hat mit Daybreak Blue
ebenfalls ein großes Upgrade erhalten,
wodurch sie kontinuierlich
GitHub-Repositorys scannen,
Schwachstellen untersuchen und
Korrekturen vorbereiten kann, selbst
wenn Ihr Computer ausgeschaltet ist. Es
gibt auch eine neue Entscheidungs-API,
die von GBT6 Luna für Klassifizierung,
Routing und Agentenentscheidungen
unterstützt wird und ein direkter
Konkurrent sowie ein „Killer“ für
Jev ist, dazu ein massives Codeex-und
Codex-CLI-Update, auf das wir später
noch eingehen werden. Und natürlich
war das Beste am Dev Day, wie Tibbo den
Knopf drückte und uns alle mit einem
weiteren Reset segnete. Es gibt noch so
viel mehr zu besprechen, aber Leute, es
würde mir wirklich viel bedeuten, wenn
ihr dieses Video jetzt liken und
abonnieren würdet, falls ihr es noch
nicht getan habt, denn viele von euch
sind tatsächlich noch keine Abonnenten
. Also tut das bitte, denn das hilft
dem Kanal wirklich und unterstützt
mich dabei, täglich Videos für euch
zu machen. Also bitte, macht das
einfach. Aber lasst uns direkt zum
heutigen Upload zurückkehren. Was
wäre, wenn deine Halloween-Kritzeleien
zu echtem Merchandise würden?
Verwandle mit Printify deine gruseligen
Designs in drei einfachen Schritten in
echte Fanartikel. Schritt eins:
Erstelle dein Design. Geister,
Kürbisse, Hexenhüte oder ein
Wortspiel, das so schlecht ist, dass es
schon wieder gruselig ist. Schritt zwei
: Packe es auf ein Produkt, einen
Hoodie, eine Tasse oder eine
Tragetasche. Printify hat über tausend
Produkte zur Auswahl. Schritt drei:
Verbinde deinen Etsy-, Shopify-oder
TikTok-Shop. Füge ein paar gruselige
Schlagworte hinzu und klicke auf
Veröffentlichen. Bestellungen werden
lokal in den USA und Europa gedruckt,
sodass sie schneller versendet werden
und du zusätzliche Gebühren
vermeidest. Keine Vorkosten, kein
Lagerbestand, keine Erfahrung
erforderlich, was perfekt für
Studenten ist. Printify Premium spart
dir bis zu 20%auf den gesamten Katalog.
Die besten Preise auf dem Markt. Starte
also noch heute Abend dein gruseliges
Merchandise mit Printify über die
Links in der Beschreibung unten. Und
danke an sie für das Sponsern des
heutigen Videos. Fangen wir mit dem
Elefanten im Raum an: GPT 6.1 Soul, das
OpenAI als "Near-Astra-Intelligenz" zum
fünffach günstigeren Preis bezeichnet
, und es ist das kosteneffizienteste
Modell für seine Leistung, das derzeit
verfügbar ist. GPT 6.1 Soul ist im
Wesentlichen ein großes Upgrade
gegenüber GPT 6 Soul, wobei OpenAI
sagt, dass es GPT 6 Astra in den
Bereichen Programmieren,
Computernutzung und professioneller
Arbeit fast ebenbürtig ist. Aber das
Verrückteste ist die Preisgestaltung.
GPT 6.1 Soul kostet nur 2 $ pro 1
Million Input-Token und 10 $ pro 1
Million Output-Token, was exakt dem
Preis von Sonnet 5.5 entspricht und im
Vergleich zu Astra günstig ist, die
bei 10 $ für 1 Million Input und 50 $
für 1 Million Output liegen. Der
Cache-Input für dieses neue 6.1-Modell
ist mit nur 10 Cent pro Million Token
sogar noch günstiger, was 95%billiger
ist als die reguläre
Soul-Input-Preisgestaltung und die
Hälfte der gecachten Input-Preise von
GPT 6 Soul. Und das soll nicht einfach
nur ein günstigeres Modell sein.
OpenAI sagt, dass GPT 6.1 Soul
erhebliche Verbesserungen gegenüber
GPT 6 Soul bei komplexen beruflichen
Aufgaben liefert, darunter
Programmierung, Fehlerbehebung,
Dokumentenverständnis und mehrstufige
Geschäftsabläufe, wobei mehrere
Bewertungen es überraschend nah an
Astra auf der „World of AI“-
Benchmark-und Vibe-Plattform
positionieren. Hier haben wir dieses
Modell rigoros getestet und sind zu dem
Schluss gekommen, dass es auf dieser
Benchmark insgesamt auf Platz drei
rangiert, was verrückt ist, da es
jetzt Sonnet 5.5 übertrifft und dabei
deutlich günstiger ist. Damit erhalten
Sie nahezu GPT 6 Astra-Intelligenz zu
praktisch einem Fünftel des Preises,
was einfach wahnsinnig ist, und in
vielen Fällen übertrifft es sogar
Opus 5.5, was irgendwie bemerkenswert
ist. Dieses Modell verfügt außerdem
über ein 1-
Million-Token-Kontextfenster, genau wie
die anderen. Und überraschenderweise
haben wir beim „World of AI“-
Benchmark für das Argumentationsniveau
festgestellt, dass GPT 6.1 Soul auf
mittlerer Stufe am besten abschneidet,
was irgendwie interessant ist. Und das
ermöglicht uns tatsächlich eine
stärkere Nutzung, denn je höher das
Argumentationsniveau, desto höher ist
natürlich der Verbrauch. Wenn Sie es
also auf „mittel“ einstellen, holen
Sie offensichtlich den besten Nutzen
daraus. Außerdem verbraucht es nicht
zu viele Token. Und Leute, dies ist ein
bemerkenswertes Tool, mit dem ihr
Benchmarks für verschiedene Arten von
Modellen durchführen könnt, sogar
für eure eigenen Endpunkte, sodass ihr
diese bewerten und sehen könnt, wie
ihr das Beste aus euren Modellen
herausholt. Und es gibt noch viele
andere Dinge, für die ihr dieses Tool
verwenden könnt. Daher empfehle ich
euch sehr, es über die Links in der
Beschreibung unten auszuprobieren. Ihr
könnt sogar kostenlos starten und auf
meine Prompt-Bibliothek zugreifen. Wenn
man sich nun die eigenen Benchmarks von
OpenAI ansieht, versteht man, warum GPT
6.1 Soul so interessant ist, denn bei
Deep Sway erzielt es 75%, ein Anstieg
von 68,8%bei GPT 6 Soul. Es hat sich
also stark verbessert, während es nur
ein Fünftel so viel kostet wie Astra.
Beim Automation Bench erzielt es 31,7%
bei etwa einem Drittel der Kosten von
Opus 5.5. Obwohl Sonnet 5.5 mit 44,7%
immer noch führend ist. Und beim
Terminal Bench Science erzielt es 57%
bei nur 0,547 $ pro Aufgabe im
Vergleich zu Astra mit 68,1%für 23,80
$. Und Opus 5.5 auf exakt demselben
Benchmark, das 58,7%bei 23,21 $
erreicht. Es schlägt also nicht jedes
Frontier-Modell, aber das
Preis-Leistungs-Verhältnis ist
lächerlich. Und „Artificial Analysis
“ erzählt im Grunde die gleiche
Geschichte, denn GPT 6.1 Soul erzielte
52 auf ihrem Intelligenz-Index, nur
einen Punkt hinter GPT 6 Astra,
während es bei maximalem Aufwand
weniger als ein Viertel pro Aufgabe
kostet, nämlich 0,72 $ gegenüber
3,326 $. Es hat außerdem vier Punkte
gegenüber GPT6 Soul gewonnen und liegt
nur zwei Punkte hinter Astra auf ihrem
Coding-Agent-Index. Also ja, OpenAI hat
mit GPT 6.1 Soul absolut abgeliefert.
Man erhält eine Leistung, die
überraschend nah an Astra herankommt,
und das zu einem Bruchteil des Preises.
Es fühlt sich fast so an, als hätte
Enthropics Veröffentlichung von Sonnet
5.5 OpenAI dazu gezwungen, hier
deutlich aggressiver vorzugehen, was
natürlich ein riesiger Gewinn für uns
alle ist. Und ich nutze GPT 6.1 Soul
tatsächlich schon selbst. Bisher bin
ich definitiv begeistert, besonders im
Rahmen meiner Pläne bei OpenAI; es ist
etwas, das ich bestmöglich nutzen will
und das mein täglicher Begleiter
werden könnte. Wenn du die besten
KI-Tools, Workflows und Neuheiten vor
allen anderen willst, abonniere meinen
kostenlosen Newsletter über den Link
in der Beschreibung unten–er ist
komplett gratis. Das Modell ist jetzt
über die API und den Chatbot
verfügbar und man kann sofort und ganz
einfach damit loslegen. Aber jetzt
werden wir dieses Modell direkt in
diesem neuen Video testen. Es wird also
etwas ausführlicher, aber ihr werdet
das Beste aus allen Informationen
herausholen, über die wir sprechen
werden. Dies ist ein wirklich guter
Test, der GPT 6.1 Soul mit Sonnet 5.5
vergleicht. Bei diesem Vergleich wurde
die Erstellung eines vollständigen 3
D-Tastatur-Montageprozesses angefordert
, der in 3GS animiert werden sollte.
Und GPT 6.1 Soul war am Ende etwa 30-
mal günstiger als Sonnet 5.5, was
einfach unglaublich ist. Genau da wird
dieses Modell wirklich interessant.
Natürlich ist die Qualität für diese
spezifische Aufgabenstellung nicht auf
dem gleichen Niveau wie bei Sonnet 5.5.
Behaltet das also im Hinterkopf. Nicht
für alles, nur für diese spezielle
Aufgabenstellung. Man bekommt zwar
nicht die absolut beste Qualität, aber
der Unterschied ist nur marginal. Wenn
man bei komplexen Programmier-und 3
D-Aufgaben vergleichbare Ergebnisse
erzielen kann und dabei nur einen
Bruchteil der Kosten hat, ändert das
die wirtschaftliche Situation komplett.
Und deshalb könnte GPT 6.1 Soul für
jeden zum täglichen Begleiter werden.
Ein weiterer verrückter Vergleich ist
GPT 6.1 Soul gegen GPT6 Astra. Beide
erhielten exakt denselben Prompt bei
ihrem höchsten verfügbaren
Reasoning-Aufwand. 6.1 Soul brauchte
etwa 10 Minuten für die Aufgabe und
kostete 1,50 $, während Astra 25
Minuten benötigte und 11 $ kostete.
Und ehrlich gesagt sieht der Output von
Soul hier wohl sogar besser aus, und
das zu einem Bruchteil der Kosten. Das
sieht man auch im Vergleich zu Opus 5.5
, das aktuell eines der besten
verfügbaren Modelle ist. Hier wurden
beim gleichen Test beide Modelle mit
demselben Prompt gefüttert. EBT 6.1
Soul war in etwa 45 Minuten für 7,15 $
fertig. Im Vergleich dazu brauchte Opus
5.5 eine Stunde und 32 Minuten für
dieses Ergebnis und kostete 14,84 $.
Soul war also in etwa der halben Zeit
für weniger als die Hälfte der Kosten
fertig. Und genau deshalb ist dies so
ein unglaubliches Modell. Das
Preis-Leistungs-Verhältnis macht es zu
einem der besten Modelle, die uns
derzeit zur Verfügung stehen. Ich
weiß, das klingt ein wenig wie Werbung
, weil ich das Modell in diesem Video
so sehr anpreise, aber es sind einfach
Fakten, basierend auf dem, was ich
bisher gesehen habe. Es sieht wirklich
nach einem großartigen Modell aus, und
meinen Tests zufolge ist es eines der
besseren Modelle, die ich auf diesem
Kanal getestet habe. Hier erhielt Soul
die Anweisung, einen Minecraft-Klon zu
erstellen. Und das ist eine wirklich
schöne Generierung, die wir von diesem
neuen Modell erhalten haben; die
Wasserphysik, die Texturen, alle
Komponenten des ursprünglichen
Sandbox-Klons wurden generiert. Wir
nähern uns also einem Punkt, an dem
diese Spitzenmodelle bei dieser
speziellen Aufgabe hervorragende
Leistungen erbringen. Es ist einfach
großartig zu sehen, denn dies ist ein
Modell, das praktisch alles wie das
Originalspiel machen kann. Und das wird
mit diesen Klonen repliziert. Es zeigt
einfach, dass selbst ein so
kosteneffizientes Modell ein solches
Output-Niveau erreichen kann, was
einfach wahnsinnig ist. Nun folgt ein
wirklich interessanter Test, bei dem
Opus 5.5 mit GBT 6.1 Soul verglichen
wird. Dies ist die Generierung des GPT
6.1 Soul. Offensichtlich hat es das
alles schneller erledigt und konnte
alles umsetzen, was basierend auf der
ersten Anweisung gefordert wurde. Aber
wenn man sich das Ergebnis von Opus 5.5
ansieht, erkennt man einen
geringfügigen Qualitätsunterschied.
Der Designgeschmack von Opus 5.5 ist
immer noch deutlich besser als das, was
wir von diesem neuen Soul-Modell
gesehen haben, was verständlich ist,
aber es ist nicht wesentlich besser als
das, was wir bei Opus sehen. Aber Opus
fügt eine Menge Details hinzu, die die
Generierung viel besser machen, was man
hier sehen kann. Dies ist wie eine
statische Generierung, nichts allzu
Außergewöhnliches, aber die
Opus-Variante hat viele verschiedene
Elemente, die sie viel realistischer
und lebendiger machen und die in der
Lage ist, all diese Dinge perfekt zu
programmieren. Als nächstes kommt der
360 °-Produktbetrachter. Und das
könnte die beste Generierung sein, die
ich für diesen speziellen Prompt von
irgendeinem Modell erhalten habe, sogar
vom Astro-Modell, denn das hier hat das
Produkt offensichtlich generiert. Es
konnte aber auch ein schönes,
elegantes und sauberes Frontend dafür
erstellen. Du hast die Möglichkeit,
alle verschiedenen Farben für das
Produkt selbst zu ändern, und es
wurden viele coole Aspekte hinzugefügt
, die das Ganze etwas lebendiger machen
. Nicht alles ist ausprogrammiert, aber
die Hauptseite sieht absolut
fantastisch aus. Ich liebe wirklich,
was sie mit dieser spezifischen
Generierung in SVG gemacht haben. Das
Modell schlägt sich ziemlich gut und
es hat offensichtlich alle diese
Ausgaben in diesem speziellen Bereich
perfektioniert. Es ist nicht auf dem
gleichen Niveau wie Opus oder gar das
neue Gemini-4-Modell, bzw. der Gemini-4
-Checkpoint, aber es ist dennoch eine
bemerkenswerte Generierung und es
schafft es, die Ergebnisse zu
perfektionieren. Eine Sache, die mir
bei all diesen Generierungen
aufgefallen ist, ist, dass es keine
losen Enden gibt. Es sind perfekte
Generierungen in fast jedem Ergebnis,
was mir wirklich gut gefällt. Es
poliert jede Ausgabe auf, und das ist
einer der Vorteile, die man diesem
Modell zuschreiben kann. Als Nächstes
kommt das, was ihr am Anfang des Videos
gesehen habt: mein Elden-Ring-Klon, den
ich von diesem Modell angefordert habe.
Und das ist einfach wahnsinnig, Leute.
Ich habe jede Komponente dieses Spiels
vollständig erstellt. Ich habe dieses
Spiel tatsächlich gespielt, also weiß
ich eine Menge darüber. Ich habe es
durchgespielt. Das ist also meine
Errungenschaft, aber es hat mich sehr,
sehr viel Zeit gekostet. Aber das ist
irre, denn man hat diese verschiedenen
Truhen. Man hat all die eigentlichen
Funktionen des Spiels, wie Parieren, um
verschiedene Angriffe abzublocken. Ich
glaube, es gibt auch den Sprungangriff.
Diese Animation wurde von diesem Modell
programmiert, was verrückt ist. Nun,
schauen wir mal, ob ich diesen Boss
tatsächlich besiegen kann. Okay, ich
habe diesen Kerl also erledigt. Mal
sehen, ob ich...Öffnen wir das zuerst.
Dann machen wir einen Sprungangriff. Ja
, der Typ hat keine Chance gegen mich.
Dann nehmen wir uns mal diesen Kerl
hier vor. Lass uns...lass uns parieren.
Alter, das hat nicht funktioniert. Aber
wir können diesen Typen erledigen. Wir
können uns sogar festlegen. Das ist an
sich schon ziemlich cool. Es gibt Magie
. Was zum Teufel macht Magie? Warte,
was? Das ist tatsächlich ziemlich cool
. Also, ich habe diesen Typen jetzt
erledigt. Und mal sehen, ob ich diese
Truhe bekomme, ob sie mir etwas bringt.
Flaschenkapazität auf vier erhöht.
Okay, das ist nett. Aber schaut euch
das mal an, Leute. Das wurde in 3GS
gemacht. Es hat so ziemlich alle
Elemente wie im Originalspiel
ausprogrammiert. Da ist dieser goldene
Baum, den man auch aus dem
Originalspiel kennt. Da sind Ruinen. Da
sind eine Menge Texturen. Sogar
Soundeffekte–wenn ich das lauter
mache, hört man sogar den Soundtrack
im Hintergrund und die Atmosphäre, das
ist einfach irre. Lass mich das lieber
wieder leiser machen, sonst ruinieren
wir uns noch die Ohren. Aber machen wir
mit unserer Reise weiter und schauen
mal, ob wir es mit diesem Boss
aufnehmen und ihn erledigen können.
Okay, ich gehe zuerst rein und schieße
meine Magie ab. Den Typen mit meiner
Magie ein bisschen bearbeiten. Okay,
bleib mal locker. GG. Ganz ruhig. Leute
, interessantes Detail am Rande. Okay.
Hey, chill mal. Ich war anfangs ein
YouTuber, als ich noch ein kleines Kind
war. Kleines Kind, also so etwa mit 12.
Und ich habe Beyblade-Videos gemacht.
Ich war tatsächlich YouTuber auf einem
anderen Kanal, über den ich nicht
reden werde, weil das etwas peinlich
ist. Aber ich habe damals viele Videos
auf YouTube gemacht, in denen ich mein
Gameplay gezeigt habe–und ich war
total mies darin. Wie dem auch sei, das
war meine erste Erfahrung, und ich
bekam ein besseres Gefühl dafür, was
man mit Aufnahmen alles machen kann,
und so bin ich eigentlich zu YouTube
gekommen. Aber Ich sterbe. Sorry. Ich
bin ein bisschen gestresst. Aber wir
sind fast da. Stirb, Alter. Mann, so
nah dran. Ich war so verdammt nah dran.
Leider konnte ich diesen Boss nicht
besiegen, aber ich versuche es beim
nächsten Mal. Also, meine zwei Cent zu
GBT 6.1 Soul: Das ist wirklich eine der
wichtigsten Veröffentlichungen von
OpenI. Nicht, weil es das
intelligenteste Modell der Soul-Reihe
ist, sondern weil das
Preis-Leistungs-Verhältnis einfach der
Wahnsinn ist. Man bekommt ein Modell,
das im Vergleich zu Astra wahnsinnig
günstig ist, dabei fast die
Intelligenz von Astra bietet und nur
einen Bruchteil kostet–das ist
einfach unfassbar. Und einige der
Praxistests machen dieses Modell zu
etwas, das man gerne als täglichen
Begleiter nutzen möchte. Ich kann also
nur empfehlen, es sich mal anzusehen.
Man kann Sonnet Opus nutzen. Ich weiß
es ehrlich gesagt nicht mal, weil es im
Moment so viele gute Modelle gibt. Es
ist offensichtlich schwer zu
entscheiden, welches Modell man als
Standard nutzt, aber man kann ja je
nach Aufgabe individuell wählen. Die
Ratenlimits für OpenAI scheinen im
Moment ziemlich fair zu sein. Wir
werden mit dem neuen Plan noch etwas
genauer darauf eingehen, aber ich finde
ihn bei den Basisplänen wirklich gut.
Das wäre also ein tolles Modell, das
man innerhalb von Codeex als tägliches
Arbeitstier nutzen kann, um dann
vielleicht zu Astra zu wechseln, das
zwar kein optimales Limit hat, oder
für komplexere Aufgaben zu Opus 5.5
oder sogar Sonic 5.5. Wenn Ihnen dieses
Video gefällt und Sie den Kanal
unterstützen möchten, können Sie
über die „Super Thanks“-Option
unten eine Spende tätigen. Oder Sie
treten unserem privaten Discord bei, wo
Sie monatlich kostenlosen Zugriff auf
verschiedene KI-Tools sowie tägliche
KI-News, exklusive Inhalte und vieles
mehr erhalten. Doch jetzt werden wir
einige der neuen Dinge enthüllen, die
heute auf dem Dev Day vorgestellt
wurden. Beginnen wir mit DOTs. Hier hat
OpenAI heute offiziell seinen „
Always-on“-KI-Agenten gestartet, so
wie wir es in unseren geleakten Videos
besprochen hatten. DOTs werden von GPT-
6 Astra betrieben und verfügen über
einen eigenen Cloud-Computer und
Browser. Sie können im Grunde rund um
die Uhr auf Ihre eigenen Ziele
hinarbeiten, selbst während Sie etwas
anderes tun–ähnlich wie man es von
Grokbot oder Muse, Metas KI-Agenten,
kennt. Sie können sich mit über 4.000
Apps verbinden, genau wie der
OpenAI-DOT-KI-Agent. Und das geschieht
über deren Plug-in-System. Sie können
tatsächlich direkt aus Slack, Teams,
ChatGPT oder sogar per Sprachanruf mit
Ihrem DOT interagieren, was ziemlich
cool ist. Das wirklich Interessante
daran ist jedoch, dass es so konzipiert
wurde, dass es mit der Zeit lernt, wie
Sie arbeiten. Ähnlich wie bei dem
persistenten Gedächtnis, das wir bei
Hermes gesehen haben. Dies ist etwas,
das Ihre Vorlieben, Ziele, Standards
und das, was Sie als gutes Ergebnis
betrachten, erlernt. Statt ständig
Prompts einzugeben oder den Agenten
Schritt für Schritt anzuleiten,
können Sie ihm ein Projekt geben, es
leiten lassen und es dann im
Hintergrund ausführen. OpenAI zeigte
ein Beispiel, bei dem DOT
Kundenfeedback überwacht, PRs
vorbereitet, Recherchen bei neuen Daten
aktualisiert, Teile von
Verkaufsabschlüssen abwickelt und
sogar die Content-Produktion
automatisiert. Ein früher Tester
stellte anscheinend fest, dass DOT
bemerkte, dass er vergessen hatte, eine
Veröffentlichung in Rechnung zu
stellen, woraufhin es die Rechnung
selbst vorbereitete und nach Erhalt der
Genehmigung versandte. Sie können
sogar den Computer des DOT öffnen und
genau beobachten, was es gerade tut.
Und mit Ihrer Erlaubnis kann es sich
auch mit Ihrem eigenen Laptop verbinden
. Für den Moment beginnt OpenAI damit,
diesen neuen KI-Agenten für
Pro-Business-, Premium-und
Unternehmenskunden auszurollen, aber
sie stellen sich vor, dass Menschen in
naher Zukunft ganze Teams aus
spezialisierten Gedanken haben, die
zusammenarbeiten. Und ehrlich gesagt
meinten viele Leute, dass es Grockbot
sowie Muse kopiert, aber es bringt
seine eigene Einzigartigkeit mit vielen
der anderen Funktionssätze ein. Als
Nächstes: Tibble hat kurz vor dem Dev
Day tatsächlich eine ziemlich wichtige
Ankündigung gemacht. OpenAI führt
wieder den 200-Dollar-Pro-Plan ein,
aber es gibt einen Haken. Die neue
Version bietet Ihnen effektiv nur die
Hälfte des API-Gegenwerts des alten
Plans. Es wurde im Grunde halbiert. Die
gute Nachricht ist jedoch, dass sie das
nervige 5-Stunden-Limit nicht wieder
einführen. Und Tibbo argumentiert,
dass die Nutzer dennoch mehr
tatsächliche Arbeit erledigen sollten,
da die Modelle selbst drastisch
effizienter werden. Nachdem ich gesehen
habe, was GBZ 6.1 Soul geleistet hat,
ergibt die Begründung hier meiner
Meinung nach viel Sinn: OpenAI treibt
die Kosten für Intelligenz so
aggressiv nach unten, dass die gleiche
Menge an Rechenleistung viel mehr
erreichen kann als zuvor. Während Sie
also technisch gesehen weniger
Nutzungskapazität für den 200-
Dollar-Monatsplan erhalten, sollten
Modelle wie GBC 6.1 Soul diese
Rechenleistung deutlich weiter strecken
. Und es gibt auch eine geschäftliche
Seite dabei. OpenAI hat zuversichtlich
IPO-Unterlagen eingereicht, obwohl Sam
Ultim gesagt hat, dass der IPO nicht
2026 stattfinden wird und der Zeitpunkt
ungewiss bleibt. Ich würde nicht sagen
, dass sie die Nutzung kürzen, weil
sie an die Börse gehen, aber während
OpenAI skaliert, werden diese Art von
Rechen-und Abonnementökonomie
eindeutig wichtig. Und wo wir von mehr
Nutzung sprechen: OpenAI hat auch einen
neuen 500-Dollar-Pro-Plan angekündigt,
wie wir in den ersten Leak-Videos
besprochen hatten. Dies ist im Grunde
eine Stufe für Vielnutzer und kommt
mit massiv höherer Nutzungskapazität,
keinem 5-Stunden-Limit und, was am
wichtigsten ist, Zugang zum neuen
Ultra-Fast-Modus. Ultra-Fast ist im
Grunde OpenAIs neue Stufe für
Premium-Geschwindigkeiten. Dies bietet
bis zu achtmal schnellere
Token-Generierung in Codecs, etwa 300
Token pro Sekunde, und bis zu sechsmal
schnellere Geschwindigkeiten über die
API. Es ist heute für GBT6 Astra über
Codeex, ChatGPT Work und die API
verfügbar, wobei GBT 6.1 Soul bald
folgen wird. Und das ist einer der
großen Gründe für den neuen Pro-Plan
, der OpenAIs höchste Nutzungsgrenzen
um das 25-Fache und mehr erhöhen wird,
und er gewährt Ihnen den Zugang zu
Ultra-Fast. Als Nächstes kommt die
Codec Security Cloud, die durch
Daybreak Blue ein massives Upgrade
innerhalb von OpenAIs cyberfähigen
Modellen erhält, und dies beinhaltet
etwas, das jetzt zum Standard wird. Es
kann Ihr gesamtes GitHub-Repo scannen,
kontinuierlich neue Commits
überprüfen, untersuchen, verschiedene
Arten von Sicherheitsproblemen finden
und sogar Korrekturen zur Überprüfung
vorbereiten, während Ihr Laptop
zugeklappt ist. Es ist im Grunde ein
ständig aktiver
KI-Sicherheitsingenieur für Ihre
Codebasis und als Plug-in innerhalb von
Codeex, der Desktop-App sowie im Web
verfügbar. Ich habe das wirklich
geliebt. Dies ist ein weiteres riesiges
Codex-Update, bei dem Sie endlich Ihren
Laptop schließen können und Ihre
Agenten für Sie arbeiten, während Sie
weg sind. OpenAI stellt
Codex-Cloud-Umgebungen vor, die Ihren
Agenten wiederverwendbare Umgebungen
mit bereits konfigurierten
Repo-Abhängigkeiten, Skripten und
Einstellungen bieten. Das bedeutet viel
weniger Einrichtung, viel schnellere
Starts und die Agenten können in der
Cloud weiterarbeiten, selbst wenn Ihr
Computer ausgeschaltet ist. Und Sie
können diese Cloud-Umgebungen sogar
von Ihrem Telefon aus steuern. Und Sie
haben sogar die Möglichkeit, auf fast
allen, oder nicht fast allen, sondern
auf allen kostenpflichtigen Plänen
darauf zuzugreifen. OpenAI hat auch die
neue Entscheidungs-API eingeführt, die
ein direkter Konkurrent zu Jev ist und
von GPT6 Luna angetrieben wird. Es
verleiht Ihrem Repo im Grunde eine
KI-Entscheidungsfindung in Echtzeit.
Sie definieren eine Frage und die
mögliche Antwort, und Luna kann
Inhalte klassifizieren, Anfragen
weiterleiten und entscheiden, was ein
Agent als Nächstes tun soll. Dies
könnte besonders nützlich für
Multi-Agenten-Systeme sein, bei denen
Sie ein schnelles und extrem günstiges
Modell als Entscheidungsebene
benötigen; es ist derzeit in einer
begrenzten Vorschau verfügbar, wird
aber in den nächsten Wochen
erhältlich sein. Ich kann nicht viel
Zeit damit verbringen, jede einzelne
Implementierung von Codeex und dem
Codeex CLI durchzugehen; aber diese
beiden separaten Anwendungen haben eine
massive Auffrischung erhalten, und
besonders das CLI hat eine UI-Änderung
bekommen. Dies wird für viele
Entwickler, die das CLI nutzen,
hilfreich sein, da es nun eine
vollständige Bildschirmoberfläche mit
besserer Lesbarkeit bietet. Sie haben
verbesserte Möglichkeiten, mehrere
Agenten wie Open Code und parallele
Arbeit zu verwalten, ohne jemals Ihr
Terminal verlassen zu müssen. Sie
können den Befehl/usage verwenden, um
Aktivität und Nutzung zu verfolgen. Es
gibt sogar die Möglichkeit, Themen mit
dem Befehl/theme zu ändern. Sie
können das Aussehen anpassen und es
gibt sogar Unterstützung für die
Verwaltung von Worktrees. Codeex kann
sogar Mermaid-Diagramme und Latex
direkt im Terminal neben ausklappbaren
Diff-Tool-Ausgaben rendern. Dedizierte
Bereiche für Status-Shortcuts und
Hinweise. Als nächstes führte OpenAI
ChatGPT Space ein, was im Grunde ein
neuer kollaborativer Arbeitsbereich
für Sie, Ihr Team und sogar die KI ist
. Es ist eine große Funktion, bei der
sie dieses neue Feature „Pages“
genannt haben, ein interaktives
Dokument, das Diagramme, Bilder,
Checklisten, Dashboards und mehr
enthalten kann. ChatGPT kann diese
Seiten tatsächlich auf der Grundlage
Ihrer Konversationen und Ihrer Arbeit
erstellen, und Ihr Team kann sie
gemeinsam bearbeiten, während es
ChatGPT, Codex oder Ihren Bot markiert,
um Aufgaben zu erledigen oder
Informationen aus verbundenen Quellen
auf dem neuesten Stand zu halten. Dies
ist eine weitere Funktion, die für
alle kostenpflichtigen Pläne im Web,
auf dem Desktop und für die mobile
Ansicht eingeführt wird. Nun, es gibt
ein paar Dinge, die ich definitiv
übersehen habe, viele kleine
Funktionen. Daher empfehle ich dringend
einen Blick auf den
Zusammenfassungs-Blog, in dem über all
die coolen kleinen Updates wie die
Plugin-Erweiterungen, die jetzt leicht
verfügbar sein werden, und ein paar
andere Dinge gesprochen wird. Ich
empfehle also sehr, sich das anzusehen,
damit Sie ein besseres Verständnis
dafür bekommen, was am DevDay passiert
ist, aber ich habe im Grunde das
Wichtigste abgedeckt. Tatsächlich habe
ich eine Sache verpasst, und das ist
der Reset, der zusammen mit dem DevDay
kam. Dabei hat Tibbo selbst einen
ziemlich lustigen Sketch auf dem DevDay
aufgeführt. Und hier hatte Sam Altman
Tibbo aus der Menge herausgerufen, er
holte seinen Knopf hervor und drückte
ihn tatsächlich, was jedem einen Reset
gab. Und das ist eine Sache, die ich an
OpenAI in letzter Zeit wirklich liebe:
Sie geben ihren Nutzern kontinuierlich
Resets und stellen sicher, dass sie
ihre Nutzer mit kleinsten Dingen wie
diesen priorisieren. Deshalb gefällt
mir das, was sie insgesamt tun,
wirklich sehr. Und das ist
offensichtlich ein weiterer Reset, den
wir in den letzten zwei Wochen erhalten
haben, was großartig ist. Ehrlich
gesagt, ein großartiger Tag. Und der
Nationalfeiertag steht in China bevor,
der meines Wissens am 2. oder 1.
Oktober ist, was auch immer es sein mag
. Das ist ein wirklich guter Hinweis
darauf, dass vielleicht ein anderes
chinesisches Labor oder nicht ein
anderes, sondern ein chinesisches Labor
kurz vor der Veröffentlichung eines
Modells stehen könnte. Aber das ist
etwas, worüber ich euch vielleicht
morgen oder übermorgen auf dem
Laufenden halten werde. Aber wie dem
auch sei, ich hoffe, euch hat das
heutige Video gefallen und ihr konntet
einen gewissen Mehrwert daraus ziehen.
Dies war ein wirklich langes Video,
daher würde es mir wirklich viel
bedeuten, Leute, wenn ihr den Kanal
abonnieren, das Video liken und es mit
euren Freunden teilen könntet. Ich
werde alle Links, die ich im heutigen
Video verwendet habe, in der
Beschreibung unten hinterlassen. Stellt
sicher, dass ihr euch die World of AI
School-Community anseht. Werft einen
Blick auf die Plattform, die
Vivecon-Plattform und den Benchmark.
Werft einen Blick auf unseren zweiten
Kanal. Schließt euch uns auf X oder,
Entschuldigung, nein, dem Newsletter an
. Schließt euch uns auf Discord an.
Folgt mir auf X. Und zum Schluss:
Stellt sicher, dass ihr euch den
YouTube-Kanal anseht. Vergesst nicht,
die Glocke zu aktivieren und das Video
zu liken. Und das war es im Grunde für
das heutige Video. Ich hoffe, es hat
euch gefallen und wir sehen uns bald
wieder. Er leidet.